the Affordable Care Act also known as
Obamacare or an email from your uncle as
forward forward forward
the communist takeover of American
values for years now Obamacare has been
the bane of Republicans existence if
Obamacare is ever implemented and
enforced we will never recover from it
this bill is an affront on the moral
morality of the provision of American
health care Obamacare is the worst piece
of legislation ever yes the worst piece
of legislation ever so good news
Fugitive Slave Act you finally offer
though but now Republicans controlling
both the White House and Congress
they've gone from talking about
repealing Obamacare to potentially being
able to do it already the House and
Senate have passed budget resolutions to
start the process and at least one
member is positively giving about it a
little over six years ago I lived in a
pretty decent house and one day I heard
a knock on the door and before I knew it
my colleagues from the other side of the
aisle had let it go loose in my house
now for six years that goat has been
messing in and destroying my house
I want to renovate my house but before I
can I have to get the goat out of the
house before it does any more damage it
makes no sense to start fixing up my
house until we get to go down voting for
the fiscal year 17 budget resolution
gets this goat out of my house
but is so specific there is just no way
that goat incident didn't actually
happen I bet he brings it up all the
time mr. speaker
NAFTA is like when you have a fleet one
morning you put your arm around what you
think is your wife but lo and behold
it's that goat again and you wonder why
they were my wife but you get these go
out of our house
and yes all week long Republicans will
be dealing with an unexpected problem
constituents at town halls furious that
Obamacare might be taken away I could
kill you right members of my family
included me that would be dead dead and
homeless if it was not for AC any yes
apparently that annoying Obamacare goat
in the house turned out to be a licensed
physician who's been saving life and a
lot of people do not want her to go
anywhere and yes I said her I'm sorry
you assume that goat doctor was a man
what the is wrong with you that's a
lady got to be doctors have family
that's holy it's actually a big kick
against if you remember eight years ago
people absolutely terrified about what
Obamacare might need this is the
stepping stone for copper take over my
communism like it or get in Germany
Obama's a Marxist socialist no don't do
this to us
victory theme you want to kill my
grandparents you cook Scooby first look
relax
President Obama did not want to kill
that guy's grandparents and if he did he
wouldn't have used health insurance he
just ordered a drum strike and then
declared them enemy combatants that was
his style so tonight let's look at
Obamacare what it does what needs fixing
and how Republicans plan to replace it
and before we start it's worth
remembering just how bad things were
before it was passed nearly forty nine
million Americans had no coverage and if
you buy for yourself insurance could
deny anyone they consider too risky some
denied entire professions like air
traffic controllers taxi cab drivers and
scuba divers and this baby was denied
coverage it just four months old for an
unexpected pre-existing condition his
parents decided to apply for individual
health coverage for Alex but they were
turned down not because of his age but
because he was too fat am I supposed to
pull my child on a diet
put him on a treadmill of course not
he's an infant look
yes I understand that you're upset but
think about it he's never going to lose
the weight with that attitude but the
point here is Obamacare was an attempt
to solve those problems it made it
illegal to deny people coverage because
of pre-existing conditions it let people
stay on their parents plan until age 26
McVeigh preventive screenings free for
everyone and creative market places
where people could shop for insurance
with potential subsidies and between all
that and Medicaid expansion more than 20
million people gained coverage putting
our uninsured rate at a historic low and
yes many people like this woman whose
treatment for breast cancer was covered
under Obamacare the law was just always
too closely associated with the man
responsible for it
I absolutely detest hearing the words
Obamacare the casket it just should have
been given a more proper name why be
named after our president okay what to
be clear it did have a proper name it
was the Patient Protection and
Affordable Care Act but that does goes
to show you it matters what people call
something would Emma Stone be as popular
if her real name was blump shart cracker
no no sorry that's that's why it's good
that she changed you and some of the
early accusations held against Obamacare
still linger just this month a
Republican official bill Aikens in
Florida throughout this classic and a
town hall here's the pradhans I have
with the Affordable Health Care Act
number one there is a provision in there
that anyone over the age of 74 has to go
before what is effectively a death panel
once they do yes they do it's been their
fault you're wrong
[Applause]
okay children all right children
is it that panel who here has read the
affordable healthcare plan I seriously
doubt that what are you talking about
the notion of death panels is just a lie
it PolitiFact's 2009 lie of the year
which is impressive considering that in
2009 America was also repeatedly told
Jason Mraz was the next big thing we
will like to win a 3-way there and look
Obamacare is not perfect it had and has
serious flaws the healthcare.gov website
was broken on day one and the president
famously made a very misleading promise
if you like your doctor you will be able
to keep your doctor period if you like
your health care plan you will be able
to keep your health care plan period the
truth is no one can promise that
insurers drop policies and doctors
change networks all the time
that is as empty a promise as a father
telling his daughter I will always keep
you safe
period really dad what about bees
what about angry swarms of bees be
honest and say I'll try to keep you safe
but these bees are not around
and I think practical problems to some
plans have deductibles so high they're
essentially unusable and in many places
premiums have increased sharply and some
insurers have dropped out although that
was partly thanks to Republicans gutting
a program in the original bill that
helps protect insurers from unexpected
loss isn't that has been something of a
pattern here
Republicans have happily complained
about the flaws in the law taking no
responsibility for fixing them and in
fact have often undermined the whole
thing but that time is now over it is
their turn to present a plan and the
clock is ticking insurance companies are
deciding right now whether to even offer
Obamacare plans next year but before you
panic there are ads on TV right now
suggesting the Republicans have been
working on something pretty special
imagine a new path forward health
insurance that provides more choices and
care at lower cost House Republicans
have a plan to get there without
disrupting existing coverage giving your
family the health care it deserves well
that sounds nice
but it is a little worrying that that
added literally encouraging you to
imagine a better health care plan close
your eyes
dream of a better way forward now open
your eyes and tell us what you came up
with because we've got nothing
and you can see something there that
ends with learn more as a better health
care plan calm but if you go there this
is the entire website a single page with
just two sentences of text and the
ad again and if you click on the
ad it'll send you back to the website
and so on and so on and so on until you
don't even want health care because
you're begging for the sweet relief of
death every time you get near something
resembling a Republican plan it seems to
just recede into the distance
in January Trump said he was working on
one and maybe it was very much
formulated down to the final strokes but
what what happened when Tom Price his
Secretary of Health and Human Services
was asked about it
and his confirmation hearing President
Trump said he's working with you and a
replacement plan for the ACA which is
nearly finished and will be revealed
after your confirmation is that true
it's true that he said that yes it's
funny because the present life with all
the time with no repercussion is that
that I see what the job will not be
happy oh if you need any more proof of
how unprepared Republicans are right now
let me show you one of the draft bills I
circulated it is just seven pages long
and it ends abruptly with the word
placeholder and one member of Congress
actually tried to spin that as a
positive
just placeholder provides the clearest
signal yet that we're working with
patients and health care groups to draft
language that balances important health
status protections with necessary risk
mitigation tools oh please if your
spouse go to a birthday card that said
placeholder
that would not be a signal they're
working on the best language to express
their feelings for you if we signal they
forgot your birthday the Kabuki
showering from the office and deep down
I think you actually know that the best
sense we currently have what Republicans
want to do is from previous plans from
both price and Paul Ryan and from these
talking points that Ryan gave out ahead
of the congressional recess you're going
to be hearing a few phrases from this a
lot in the coming months so let's take a
moment to understand what they actually
mean and let's start with the big one
which Ryan has been talking up a great
deal what we believe is the right way to
go which is what our plan is our
refundable tax credits for people to go
be able to buy affordable coverage yes
responsible tax credits basically free
money to help pay your premiums which is
a little surprising coming from Paul
Ryan a man who probably takes wages by
writing on the check finder jobs and
market has DS has more value but but you
should know this document suggests tax
credits will be based on age not income
meaning theoretically sixty one-year-old
billionaire Bill Gates will give a
bigger subsidy than a 27 year olds
making minimum wage and Gates clearly
does not need that money you'll just
blow it on more ten dollar haircuts and
orthopedic sweaters so the real risk
here is subsidies ending up too small
for those who need them the most Tom
Price once proposed a credit of twelve
hundred dollars to people's aged
eighteen to thirty five and three
thousand dollars to people 50 and up
which is roughly a third of the cost of
the most bare-bones plans on the market
today a tax credit that small helps
cover your health insurance the way a
song covers your dad's are it doesn't
and there's something that is
fundamentally wrong about that now
now the next big come in here is health
savings account or HSA s
tax-free accounts where you can save
money to pay for health care costs
Republicans love these things in your
experience why do these savings account
what why are you pushing so hard for
them why do you think the respective
because you're spending your own money
as opposed
it's like when my daughter goes to the
mall with my credit card or when I go to
the mall with my credit card our
purchases come back quite different okay
selling aside that healthcare is nothing
like shopping at the mall shouldn't you
come back with different purchases than
your daughter regardless of whose credit
card you have if you came back to mall
with a tongue ring a bottle of Manic
Panic hair dye and a gas queen crop top
it was raise a lot of questions having
nothing to do with health care yep the
King problems with HFA's should be
obviously if they're great for rich
people they're basically a tax shelter
but if you're too poor to fade or you
get sick enough to blow through what you
face you're not going to be covered and
you have that song problem again and
people seem to understand that just
looking the reaction when Joni Ernst try
bringing them up at a town hall mental
savings account
that is an appropriate reaction when
your problem is I don't have enough
money and the proposed solution is well
if you ever do is a very fancy piggy
bank so so let's move on to another key
idea block grants a phrase perfectly
designed to bore you because it combines
block the most nothing shape with grant
your co-workers nothing boyfriends I
don't believe we've met
yes we have six times I'm grant Paul
Ryan wants to use block grants to fund
Medicaid which largely provide health
care to be poorest Americans basically
he wants to stop guaranteeing to pay
each state a percentage of their
Medicaid costs and instead just send
them a fixed block of money but it costs
start to rise and the Block Grant
doesn't keep pace guess what it's that
song songs the song song song and you
should know a few years ago Ryan
proposed a block grant program that a
study estimated could kick as many as
twenty and a half million people off
Medicaid over a decade that's a kind of
evil so chilly we burn all you just
don't see it coming it's like if you
found out that grant was a serial killer
I kill in plain sight for non can
remember my face I am grant we've now
met seven times now let's move on to the
final big talking point here and I'll
let Paul Ryan explain we believe that
state high-risk pools are a smarter way
of guaranteeing coverage for people with
pre-existing conditions yes high-risk
pools now they may sounds like something
you find at Jeremy pivens house but what
they actually do is isolate the sickest
people in their own insurance group now
in theory this brings everyone else's it
area insurance rates down but there is
an obvious problem here again those
pools are going to be incredibly
expensive which is fine if the
government subsidizes them properly but
if it doesn't that's right it's song
o'clock everybody because three years
ago a study estimated that adequately
funding high-risk pools just to maintain
Obamacare levels of coverage would cost
around one hundred and seventy eight
billion dollars a year
guess how much Tom Price set aside three
billion
over three years that is one 178 of what
is needed imagine you asked for 178
pounds of grade a premium hunk but
instead of Chris Evans someone brought
you six of his severed toes but on
crisis plan is six severed hunk shows so
so those are the four big bullet points
but perhaps the most revealing thing
about this document is not what's inside
it but what is not in there because
there is no replacement for the
individual mandate Obamacare's
requirement that you have insurance or
pay a penalty and it is the thing that
people hate the most the individual
mandate is unconstitutional we got to
get rid of the individual mandate I
believe that is a freedom killing part
of the Affordable Care Act out the gate
that should be repealed get rid of the
individual mandate who's got two thumbs
and hates the individual mandates this
guy but but the mandate keeps
younger healthier people in the system
which is crucial to lower the cost for
everyone else and to keep in popular
provisions like among other things not
punishing fat babies the Republican
solution is to make it really painful
for you to get insurance again if you
drop it at any point for any reason they
use the positive sounding term
continuous coverage incentive but it has
to involve some kind of penalty maybe a
higher premium or even denial of
coverage and they are not keen to talk
about details bear remember the
placeholder from earlier that was in
place of an explanation of the
continuous coverage incentive basically
this is a subject so toxic they'd rather
just go abruptly silent much like when
you're a white person singing karaoke
and you realize oh oh we have an n-word
coming up
so Republicans are in a real bind here
they need a plan and food and what price
and Ryan have given them some Farsi to
shift costs from the government's to the
people and from the healthy to the sick
and fewer people are going to be covered
so good luck fixing that Republicans oh
and there's actually one more problem
here because you remember how much
you gave President Obama for saying you
can keep your doctor let me remind you
what Donald Trump has promised that you
are going to do everybody's got to be
covered this is an unrepeated a say no
no the lower 25% they can't afford
private but universal health care I am
going to take care of everybody I don't
care if it cost me votes or not
everybody's going to be taking care much
better than taking care of now who pays
for it
the government is going to pay for it
but we're going to save so much money on
the other side but for the most part
it's going to be a private plan and
people are going to be able to go out
and negotiate great plans with lots of
different competition with lots of
competitors with great companies and
they can have their doctors they can
have their plans they can have
everything they can have everything
period
so anything short of that is a disaster
and insurers are going to need an answer
soon Republican so tick-tock
- you don't get to sleep
over you're right out of this one
[Applause]